Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new video for the batman movie clips and
behind the scenes videos that everyone's been
posting the past couple of days you've probably
been seeing it all over social media instagram
tick tock facebook everywhere there's so many cool
easter eggs so we'll break it all down i waited a
couple extra days before making my videos just to
see if anything extra cool would wind up dropping
and turns out it did we did see a big superman
easter egg on the set this morning so i'll explain
that too if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos of course i'll
be doing bonus videos until the movie gets here
it was delayed again recently now the movie is
coming out march 22nd 2022 but i'll just number
these as we go along just to stay organized so
starting with the big set videos first first we
have a video of robert pattinson's batman on top
of the clock tower here the scene was being shot
day for night meaning that they filmed the scene
when there's light outside but they film it using
camera settings and then post-production to alter
the footage making it look like it's happening at
night notice how prominent his cape is this just
seems like a version of the trademark batman scene
you get from pretty much all the batman movies
where at some point in the movie he has an iconic
scene brooding looking out over the city then
launches into flight gliding out over the city
christian bale's batman did it ben affleck's
batman even michael keaton's batman did it a lot
the cape itself has always been used as a big part
of the glider mechanism of all the batman costumes
there's another set video of him entering and
exiting the bat cave with catwoman in their
motorcycles you actually get a much better look
at his costume as well it looks way more badass
up close like this a lot of the earlier pictures
from the set that we'd seen were very blurry
we didn't really get to see all the different
parts of it but look at how many gadgets he has
most people are drawing comparisons to lee
burmejo's version of the batman suit with
the way the armor plating looks obviously a lot
of people have theories about what's going on
with the batman symbol it almost looks like
he can pull out the two different pieces the
two different sides of his bat symbol and
use them as batarangs to throw at people
and there's the big theory about them actually
being the two different signs of the gun handle
that was used to kill his parents most versions
of comic book batman keep the gun that was
used to kill his parents at various points but
there was actually a story that kevin smith did
for the batman anniversary a little while ago
where he actually melted the gun down and used
it to make his bat symbol kevin smith would lose
his mind if they wind up doing that in this movie
most people are looking at his gauntlets here
thinking this is a big court of owl's easter
egg just because these look exactly like the
same type of gauntlets that the talons wear
if we're talking about doing new things that the
movies have not done before court of owls would be
one of the easiest slam dunks for matt reeves
to go to at some point even though the movie
itself seems like it's going for more of a seven
in zodiac aesthetic in terms of references i'm
assuming because it looks like catwoman is leaving
and entering the bat cave with him during these
and on their motorcycles this is much later in the
film after they started to work together most of
the trailer footage that we saw is only taken from
less than like 25 percent of the movie and during
that it seems like he's catching her burgling this
rich person's house for the very first time it
would be funny if this winds up being wayne manor
there was also a version of a batman story where
one of their early encounters is him catching her
burgling wayne manor before she knows that he's
bruce wayne and before he knows the catwoman is
selena kyle their motorcycles also look way more
badass up close too heavily customized and they
look like they're right out of batman the animated
series with this really stylized design we've seen
the inside of his bat cave so it just seems like
he heavily customizes all of his vehicles which is
typical for batman but you do have to remember the
way their costumes look kind of the pair down look
even though they're very aggressive looking all
this is meant to look very simplistic compared to
more modern batman movies that have been the older
versions of the character with much more advanced
technology this is still batman year two so given
enough time he would also evolve the same level
of technology that say ben affleck's batman has
in his movies then there's all the set video that
people have been posting of them on the steps in
the aftermath of the car crash this all looks
like it's happening around the mayor's funeral
we've seen a lot of trailer footage there where
there's this big attack from the riddler this
is actually what the riddler looks like during
this scene like he's there in the background
just kind of keeping tabs on everything while
it's all going down you get a much better look
at robert pattinson's character pulling up in what
looks like his daily driver which is a 1963 chevy
corvette stingray remember it's a batman movie so
they're mixing and matching a lot of different era
so everything looks kind of old-timey very gothic
even though this is happening during modern day
speaking of special cars there was also a modern
purple maserati with gold highlights spotted
on the set no i don't think it belonged to the
joker everything that matt reeves has said about
the movie has been that the joker isn't a huge
character in this first new batman movie there
have been all kinds of rumors this past year that
they'll cast a new joker for one of the sequels
and there might be some easter eggs for the
joker somewhere during this movie but apparently
according to rumors he himself is not supposed to
appear on screen during this first movie but he
does exist in this universe here's a really good
picture of a lot of the main standing together
you have catwoman standing next to carmine falcone
a lot of people think this is an indication that
they're actually doing a big catwoman easter egg
from the long halloween and dark victory comics
so during those she actually believes that she's
the illegitimate daughter of carmine falcone later
those comic books wind up debunking that theory
it doesn't wind up being true her father winds up
being some other person but for a lot of the story
she herself believes that she is his illegitimate
daughter you also probably noticed a really big
easter egg for michael keaton's batman movies
so if you look at the boots that she's wearing as
part of her costume there she's wearing the exact
same boots or replicas of the boots that michelle
pfeiffer's catwoman wore during batman returns
they've only been filming for a little while but i
wouldn't be surprised if we spot more easter eggs
from the older batman movies maybe even some
easter eggs from the classic adam west batman
a lot of the mise and scene of this version of
gotham the aesthetic looks a lot like tim burton's
batman movie aesthetic most of those designs when
you talk about the really iconic designs of that
gothic version of batman came from anton first
usually when people are talking about the really
mind-blowing designs of gotham they're talking
about his designs those are such a big deal that
they've actually influenced a lot of the modern
batman films even though each new director kind
of does their own thing like zack snyder has his
own design language for the way his gotham looks
but a lot of all the new batman movies borrow
a little bit in some way from anton first
especially the arkham games which most of you
probably played at least a little of we get a
much better look at colin farrell's penguin in the
light of day and no joke if someone didn't tell
you that colin farrell was playing the penguin in
this movie almost no one would have guessed that
this was him the makeup job the prosthetics are so
complete that he's totally unrecognizable i hope
this movie winds up winning an award for some of
those makeup jobs this version of the penguin is
given his trademark name mostly because the shape
of his face in his nose make it look like he has
a penguin's face unlike the more comic booky
version who is also extremely short and very
very fat with his entire body resembling the body
of a penguin speaking of tim burton movies by the
way danny devito's penguin literally looked like a
penguin because of his deformities with the webbed
hands and the way he had to waddle around like
a penguin but this morning if you heard people
talking about superman inside the new robert
pattinson batman movies what was happening is
that somebody actually caught pictures of a group
of halloween party-goers behind the scenes one
of them was dressed in a very christopher reeve
looking superman costume meaning that either matt
reeves is seriously messing with us from the set
of the movie and they just put one of these extras
in a superman costume for fun or superman really
does exist in the world of robert pattinson's
batman movies so just to be clear obviously one
of two things they're messing with us or this is
just a halloween party goer wearing a halloween
costume that looks like superman's costume not
superman the character himself actually appearing
in the movie here's the thing when it comes to
other big dc characters that aren't part of the
batman comics like superman wonder woman aquaman
the other justice league characters everything
that matt reeves has said the past couple of years
has made it sound like his movie wasn't supposed
to be directly connected to the dc eu movies
the way that say like james gunn's new suicide
squad movie is connected to justice league
because for example harley quinn from the dc eu is
in that movie firmly placing it in the dc eu she's
playing the same version of her character from the
first suicide squad movie from birds of prey so
it's really easy to place that in the continuity
like shazam is meant to be connected to justice
league because you have henry cavill's superman at
least it's supposed to be henry cavill superman in
his costume appearing at the end of that movie but
everyone associated with the new batman movie say
that it's supposed to be doing its own thing in
its own little bubble of continuity and that's why
everything looks like it's happening pretty close
to present day like the lincoln navigator in this
crash scene is from the last six to eight years or
so so pretty late model implying that the movie is
taking place at least somewhere in the 2010s if
not closer to present day and in the ben affleck
justice league batman timeline his version of
batman would have been in his late 30s around this
time about 10 years older than robert pattinson's
batman per the timeline of the batman movie you
have to remember that batman donned the cape and
cal around his mid-20s and the movie is supposed
to be batman year two so this is late 20's batman
don't worry if it sounds confusing matt reeves is
going to get asked a thousand questions about where
this fits in the continuity and potential for
future justice league crossovers when they hit
the press tour because the movie isn't coming
out till march 2022 obviously that's not going to
start till early 2022 so it'll still be a while
so we'll continue to get a bunch of set videos
and easter eggs from behind the scenes so it'll
be going to try and spot everything and see if
there's anything else that's just as big as this
superman easter egg just trying to connect it to
other big dc movies for now though my assumption
is without the addition of the flash sort of tying
everything together with a multiverse matt reeves
is just planning on building out his own little
batman-centric trilogy of movies with potential
for more spin-offs for other characters within
that but if you spotted any other big easter
eggs and all these behind-the-scenes set videos
and clips or pictures just write them below in
the comments well you wait for everything click
here for the boys season 3 trailer jensen ackles
is going to be playing a really big character
and click here to re-watch the batman trailer a
billion more times thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!